what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with thor yes we are the god of
hammer storyline and we finally get the
revelation of who the god of hammers is
and it's really really cool so here's
the thing uh in the first video we
basically talked about how thor's hammer
over the course of this run uh that
donnie cates has been writing that
essentially the enchantment like the
worthiness enchantment has basically
gone away so anybody can pick up the
hammer of thornel and essentially the
hammer of four had just gone missing and
nobody really knew where it went to but
what we also realized is that the hammer
of thor whoever was wielding it had
actually attacked the dwarves of the
davalier and basically obliterated them
now what we also find out as we open up
with the story is we end up finding out
that the hammer whoever's wielding it
has basically attacked the other realms
right the nine realms that are out here
the realm of muspelheim and like the
realms of jotenheim and all these places
have all been attacked by the hammer now
it doesn't mean that there are no
survivors there are people who survived
the experience perhaps because they
weren't there perhaps because they
suddenly just had the power to do so
we're not really given a definitive
answer here instead all we're really
told is that they had survived their
experience in facing off against the god
of hammers now again this is a pretty
significant thing because these are
realms that are full of some pretty
powerful people the rock trolls and like
angela and people like that i mean these
are formidable foes and so of course we
switch back over to thor who's basically
burying itre of the of the dwarves right
kind of the forge master the guy who was
the one that built mjolnir in the first
place and one of the funny things that
happens is that as thor is basically
paying homage to itri and he's on his
knees of course saying a bit of a prayer
and then offering a burial that falls in
line with the dwarven traditions that
he's met by odin who's just like that's
enough right like a king cannot rule
from his knees boy and thor in turn is
just like i've had enough of this and a
small little skirmish breaks out between
the two of them i wouldn't really call
it a true full-on fight i mean it is a
cool fight to see and it is cool to see
thor overpowering odin but it's really
one of those hits where it's just like
thor attacking odin knocking him to the
ground and then thor just lets loose and
it's just like this is all your fault
right like everything that's happened so
far is your fault donald blake going
insane during the prey story arc is
because you basically created a
personality out of nowhere bonded it to
me and then in turn i would jump back
and forth between the two but once i
returned to my normal self and i stayed
thor i had no idea this guy was
basically trapped in this other
dimensional realm with no conceivable
way to leave he was like this whole
hammer this whole enchantment the thing
that you've done here taking a cosmic
entity and binding it to mjolnir like it
was only a matter of time before
something like this happened everything
you touch odin every single thing you
touch no matter what it is it all comes
to an end everything that you touch
leads to ruin and death you are a
walking talking definition of bad luck
and the thing about this is that odin
acquiesces and odin's like yes like
believe me i am totally aware of this
right it's kind of been this guilt that
odin has been carrying around for quite
some time that as he was the all-father
and when he was ruling over asgard he
was pretty hard on thor he was pretty
hard on his sons the idea was to
basically mold thor and also kind of
fall in line with like how he had always
sort of done things but at the end of
the day odin wasn't much of a father to
thor and so when you have this situation
where his son is just letting loose on
him basically spilling all these
realities to odin himself one of the
things that that odin has to have to
contend with and has to come to terms
with is the fact that this really is all
his fault you cannot take a cosmic
entity
bind it to a mortal artifact and believe
it'll stay that way forever somewhere
along the line something will change and
whether it's because odin was hubris and
he never really thought he'd have to
deal with the consequences of it or if
he had just simply never considered the
possibility of it it all falls on the
shoulders of him but in the midst of
this argument between the two suddenly
they're whisked away to the realm of the
frost giants right to the realm of
jotunheim and that's when loki reveals
all these frost giants have been
destroyed by the god of hammers and
that's when he asked the question like
have you misplaced anything lately thor
of course you know it's a rhetorical
question but as the three of them sit
down and as they meet the whole thing
here is that at some previous point in
time thor said let there be peace or let
there be thunder and when loki asked the
question like you're those are your
words correct right like you're you know
your great coronation when you were
officially crowned all father of asgard
well where is your piece now right like
where where is your thunder where is
mjolnir where is this hammer what's
going on here and how could somebody
possibly get a hold of your weapon and
start laying waste to all the different
realms that exist out here and so that's
when he asks like who is he right who is
the god of hammers and the immediate
response of odin is like this is
nonsense right he says the god of
hammers is a myth an errant prophecy the
likes of which i have crushed and tossed
aside for thousands of years but in the
end loki makes a great counter-argument
here he says like but aren't we living
myths us as guardians we're myths
according to the mortal people right and
we essentially have been since like the
third celestial host when they told us
not to get involved in the affairs of
mortal men right so like ever since then
we have basically been mythical beings
but we are in effect gods among men and
ultimately where odin says like this is
different he says if i were such a god
and of course you know thor ends up
cutting him off but at the end of the
day loki makes his point here he says
listen to me both of you as we speak the
forces of the 10 realms have taken up
arms against you they believe this
assault no matter the assailant to be as
guards doing to be your doing thor so
far i've been able to keep them from
letting loose but i do not think i can
hold them for much longer so i don't
claim to understand what is happening
between the two of you but if i may get
over it because no matter what you claim
to believe this prophecy this myth is
real and loki goes as far as to say that
like he looked it up right he's like any
evidence out there anything that details
the prophecy of the the god of hammers
has basically been destroyed and it was
destroyed recently so whoever this
whoever is wielding this god or willie
mjolnir by whoever this god of hammers
is destroyed the prophecy there's no
real information on this person all we
know is that there was a prophecy
somewhere along the line that somebody
would come along and they would
basically like this god of hammers would
show up on the scene right the god of
hammers will rise as it's described he
will ignite the ten realms and he will
take the last king of asgard and then
there will be nothing nothing but the
distant sound of a forge burning raging
as the god of hammers reshapes the world
and that's when odin's like okay so like
we're talking about another war of
realms and that's when loki's like no
you misunderstand the text is literal
right it's not a it's not a an
interpretive thing right it's not war
it's not you know he will ignite the ten
realms a fight will ensue between the
two between all these different groups
we've done that dance we know what a war
of realms looks like that's not what
this text means they will not go to war
the 10 realms will burn the 10 realms
will be destroyed and so ultimately odin
goes to initially chime in and basically
speak to thor but that's when thor's
like the bifrost is coming now here's
the important thing to understand and
this is something that's that's pretty
intrinsic here i'm not 100 sure about
this but i don't believe thor knows the
actual story of mjolnir we as the reader
do right we know that at one point in
time there was a cosmic entity that
manifested in the form of a cosmic storm
and that odin had faced off against it
and that odin had confined that cosmic
entity into a piece of uru metal which
in turn was forged into mjolnir but i'm
not entirely sure thor knows the actual
story of mjolnir right how all that
transpired and if he does just by the
look of odin and the way he seems a
little desperate in so far as his desire
to explain or at least to tell this
thing to thor it may be something that
we simply just don't know but whatever
the case is when the bifrost emerges
it's both throgg who's basically the
leader of thor security to a degree as
well as sif right the the sister of
heimdall who is essentially replaced
heimdall and that's when like they send
thor to this particular location and
when he asks the question like where are
we right what realm is this that's when
thor sees the sign of broxton oklahoma
now this is one of those times where
when we covered the j michael cerzinski
run on thor we talked about how the
events of rocks in oklahoma would never
really go away they would always be
there right that's one of those elements
where initially it was a little
uncertain if it was going to be
important during strzinski's run but the
more it stuck around going into the
events of like siege on asgard and
things like that civil war the more you
realize that essentially broxton wasn't
going anywhere that brockton was going
to be a mainstay of thor's mythos for
quite some time for those of you guys
who don't know the significance of
broxton oklahoma the idea here is that
following the events of thor
disassembled colloquially known as thor
ragnarok when odin's son had basically
died and asgard was destroyed that when
he returned he ended up bringing asgard
back but when he did he basically took
the kingdom of asgard to brockton
oklahoma and there were some pretty
hilarious stories where the townspeople
just didn't like them being there and
they would like bicker with the
townspeople different things along those
lines but essentially that was the home
base of asgard for quite some time
eventually asgard ended up becoming
asgardia following the events of siege
when it was destroyed and rebuilt by
iron man and then it basically orbited
saturn for a little while but the
important thing here is broxton was kind
of like thor's second home to a degree
right it was the re it was a place where
asgard was essentially reborn it's it's
a significant place for him and so when
he gets there with broxton having been
destroyed seemingly whoever this god of
hammers is is going after everything
that is significant to thor odin's son
himself as opposed to just arbitrarily
attacking things but in his anger and in
his frustration thor summons the hammer
to himself believing that it would
basically bring the god of hammers along
with him the problem is that when the
hammer comes the hammer in turn just
like crashes directly into thor it
doesn't simply respond to his grasp
where he would just normally catch it
and so ultimately he's like what in the
hell is going on right like how is any
of this happening right and so
ultimately he starts to realize
somebody's there and he asked the
question who is that right like who is
that that's out there and that's when
this voice basically shows you know
appears to him and says thor you know my
name you've always known it and it says
i am the god of hammers in essence what
what it look what looks to be going on
here is the sentient storm the cosmic
entity that was confined within mjolnir
has basically broken free and taken
control of mjolnir itself so it is a
personal manifestation of the hammer the
rightful owner of mjolnir has finally
returned so with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end i
gotta say i love the god of hammer
storyline i love pretty much everything
that donnie kates writes but i'm really
excited to see what happens next so uh
thank you all for watching and i will
catch you all later
peace
bye